and finally new rule please don't make
the olympics into the oscars
oh what's that they they did already
yeah you know back in april when the
oscars aired i commented in this space
that the theme of that evening
was we dare you to be entertained
lest your mind waver for a few hours
from thinking about these sad things and
bad people in the world well
thank god we found some of those bad
people in the olympics now and not a
moment too soon
the director you know that
that was sarcasm
[Laughter]
the director of the opening ceremony was
fired hours before what did we
before the event because they found out
there was a holocaust joke in a comedy
routine he did decades ago
well you know context is everything
obviously didn't strike people as beyond
the pale at the time
young people have to stop flattering
themselves that they're nostradamus
and what have foreseen had they been
around then everything that's
unacceptable now
and for further context mel brooks wrote
one of the most successful
musicals of all time around the song
springtime for hitler
why do we allow the people who just want
to [ __ ]
to always win days before that firing
the opening ceremony's musical director
musical director was also forced out
because someone dug up an interview with
him from 1994
where he admitted to bullying classmates
as a child
as a child remember when your teacher
used to
try and scare you by saying this is
going to go on your permanent record
yeah no longer an empty threat now
and the
and the creative director of the entire
shebang of the whole olympics got [ __ ]
canned because he once made a fat joke
in a private conversation
this is called a purge it's a mentality
that belongs in stalin's russia
how bad does this atmosphere we are
living in have to get
before the people who say cancel culture
is overblown
admit that is in fact an insanity that
is swallowing up the world
[Applause]
i'm back not the audience i'm back
they're still and that is not a
conservative position
my friends my politics have not changed
but i am reacting to politics that have
and this is yet another example of how
the woke invert
the very thing that used to make
liberals liberals
snitches and [ __ ] that's not being
liberal
the associated press is a real news
organization yeah
so why am i reading this headline
olympic surfing exposes whitewashed
native hawaiian roots
yeah the olympics added surfing this
year good surfers deserve to be
recognized as athletes
i'm sorry what i meant to say is no
that's cultural appropriation
the ap says that for hawaiians probably
all two of them
including surfing in the olympics is an
extension of the racial indignity
seared into the history of the game and
their homeland when white outsiders took
over their spiritual art form
or just people having fun in the ocean
i must say of all the violations of the
woke penal code
cultural appropriation just might be the
dumbest of all
first of all there are 25 000 islands in
the pacific how do we know a hawaiian
was the first to stand on a board in the
water
[Applause]
it seems like something anyone in any
ocean would eventually get around to
and if you're a surfer it doesn't matter
if you're black white or in between you
all taste the same to sharks
but
but let's say hawaiian did invent
surfing should he or she have kept it to
themselves
most of human history is a horror story
but the good parts are about different
groups coming together and sharing
it's sort of the whole point of the
olympics
which
which itself comes from greece where
wrestling was invented as a way for
completely heterosexual men to get to
know each other
badminton has roots in india tennis
comes from france
skiing from scandinavian taekwondo from
korea
judo was appropriated from the far east
and skateboarding from the far
out what is this new rule that the first
thing to do
that the first to do something are the
only ones who get to have it
jewish people spent most of their
history wandering but when they see
other people milling around they don't
say can you not that's sort of our thing
you know change is not synonymous with
progress
newer doesn't automatically mean better
this new idea that each culture must
remain in its own
separate silo is not better it's not
progress
and in fact it's messing with one of the
few ideas that still really does make
this melting pot called america great
not everything is about oppression
stealing natural resources from
indigenous peoples yes of course
that is exploitation but i swear not one
beach boy's song resulted in any
hawaiian having less waves to surf
not one african record buyer stopped
purchasing local music
after paul simon made graceland
[Laughter]
but lots of white buyers in america were
turned on to and then bought african
music
and today korean boy bands make
western style music you don't get to
number one singing this
and that's the great thing about
cultural mixing it makes things better
for everyone
bts can be a hit in america and i can
get kimchi on a taco
isn't that better than everyone walling
itself off from outsiders i thought
walls were supposed to be bad
but we're living now in a world where
straight actors are told they can't play
gay roles and white novelists aren't
allowed to imagine what it'd be like to
be a mexican immigrant
even though trying to inhabit the life
of someone else is almost the very
definition of empathy
the bedrock of liberalism and by the way
if anyone deserves to [ __ ] about
stealing in the olympics
it's the horses in the equestrian events
who have to watch humans get medals for
everything
they do
you